-We're about to play a gam
called Drinko.
Now, Kevin, you requested
that we played Drinko.
Why is that?
-Because you're not good.
You're not good at Drinko.
-I am not good at this game.
-And I was like, if I lose
what's the big deal?
I get a chance
to drink for free.
♪♪♪♪
-Drinko, would you like to
explain how this game works?
-[ Robotic ] Yes, Mr. Hart
Mr. Fallon, welcome to Drinko.
In this game, the two of you
will take turns
climbing my stairs and droppin
two of your colored discs
into the Drinko board.
The disc will clink down
and land in these plastic cups
containing some of
my favorite beverages,
such as Capri Sun,
mulled wine and pea...soup
-I'm sorry, what? What'd he say?
-Pea soup.
Your opponent
must drink a cocktail
of the two chosen drinks.
-Okay, very good.
Thank you, Drinko.
Kevin, you're our guest.
Why don't you climb up there
and make the first cocktail?
-Pretty easy for me
to climb these stairs
in my cross-training sneakers.
-Oh, give me a break.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone has their --
Yeah, yeah.
-Class.
-Alright.
[ Clears throat ]
-Now drop your first disc,
Kevin.
-Alright, here we go. Come on,
pea soup, come on, pea soup.
Mulled wine.
-Now your second drink.
-What is that?
-Drop your second disc.
-Mulled line is like all sorts
of like cinnamon sticks
and herbs and things.
-Well, I'll tell you
off the bat,
cinnamon sticks give me gas.
So you got to deal with that
on your own time.
-Drop it.
-Ready?
-Wait. Should I get
this one out of the way?
Sorry. Thank you, Drinko.
-There you go.
-How you doing, buddy?
-Not good.
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go.
-Oh, there he goes.
You'll be drinking
mulled wine and...
Hennessy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, Drinko.
-That kills me,
how the black guy
somehow mysteriously picks
Hennessy. Okay.
Alright. Yeah, okay.
-I did not plan that!
It's all random!
-Yeah, it's all random, right?
Okay, black guy, what's next
You got some Colt 45 in there?
-No, come on!
[ Laughter ]
-Geez, boy, I tell you.
-Mix them up.
-I pour it in there, right
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I pour them both in there
-Yes.
-Alright.
-Glug, glug, glug, glug.
-I got to drink the whole thing?
-I think so, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?
What's y'all problem?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience groans ]
-Eww!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good to have you on the show.
Congratulations on everything.
This is what you get.
[ Audience chanting
"chug, chug, chug" ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Don't move, don't move,
don't move, don't move.
-James, it's your turn.
Mount me.
-Don't move, Kevin.
[ Laughter ]
-Ascend the staircase.
-Oh, God.
-And drop two discs.
-Oh.
-[ Grunting ]
-Alright.
-Drop it.
-How you feeling?
-[ Hisses ]
-Alright. Alright.
Well, I'm gonna go over
this way maybe.
-Pea soup!
-No, no, no!
No, not pea soup!
-Pickle juice!
-Pickle juice.
Pickle juice is big.
-I didn't even see
pickle juice on there.
-I got it, Drinko.
-You're welcome.
-Thank you, Drinko.
-Nice shoes.
-Hey, thank you, Drinko.
-Hey, no problem.
You look good in blue.
Drop it, James.
[ Audience chanting "pea soup" ]
-No, no, no, no.
[ Chanting continues ]
Oh! No, no, no, no!
No, please, no!
What is it?
-Capri Sun.
-Yes!
Capri Sun and pickle juice
That's my diet.
That's fantastic.
That's my diet I've been on.
Yeah,
Capri Sun and pickle juice
-Mmm, so delicious.
-That is so -- That is so --
That's a white guy.
-That looks like champagne
-It does, right?
That's pickle juice?
-Yes.
-Oh.
-Oh, that don't look good.
[ Audience groans ]
Even though he said that's
Capri Sun, after seeing that
I don't believe it.
I don't believe it one bit
-Alright.
This looks gross. Okay.
[ Audience chanting
"drink, drink, drink" ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ugh.
-Not too shabby, James.
Now for the final round.
Both of you fellows are goin
to mount me at the same time
drop a disc into me
simultaneously.
Whosever just lands
in the cup first wins
and the loser has
to combine both cups
and drink the final cocktail
-Wait.
Whoever dro-- Whoever's disc -
I think I'm drunk.
Let's wait a sec.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm definitely not,
I'm definitely not,
but I'm going to throw up
all over the place.
-He said the first one --
-That goes in --
-Wins.
The other fellow drinks it
-Okay, so whoever's disc
gets down first.
-Does not have to
drink the beverages.
-I got it.
-[ Grunting ]
Those shoes are so light.
-No wonder why
I beat you up here.
It's because of
my cross trainers.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Ready, gentlemen?
When I say "three,"
drop your disc.
One, two, three.
-Capri Sun and Tang.
James drinks.
-What is it?
-Capri Sun and Tang.
-Capri Sun and Tang?
-No, no!
-Yes!
-No!
It's killing me
how the black guy got Hennessy
[ Laughter ]
But he gets all kinds of juice
-You're the champ.
[ Laughs ]
You're the champ!
Here we go!
-Why do you keep getting juice?!
-Kevin wins.
-Here we go, Tang and Capri Sun.
[ Laughter ]
Always good to see you, man.
You're the best.
I'm so excited about this.
Here we go.
-I should've known it was rigged
when I saw the white glove
I should've known.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, get --
-Pea soup!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Yes!
-What'd you have
for breakfast?
-Oh, no, actually,
actually don't do it.
Don't do it, brother.
[ Audience groans ]
-I just want to do --
I'll do a sip.
I'll just do a sip, alright?
-No, you got to drink that
'cause it's at the bottom.
If you're gonna do it, do it
[ Audience chanting
"chug, chug, chug" ]
♪♪♪♪
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Drinko!
-Not bad, actually.
Not bad. Not too shabby.
-Oh, God.
-Hey, Nike, if you're watching
I'll have my own sneakers,
as well.
I really deserve it.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm the winner?
No, I'm the loser.
Kevin Hart is the champ righ
there, everybody. Give it up
[ Cheers and applause ]
Taraji P. Henson, everybody!
We're about to play a game
called Drinko.
Drinko, do you want to explain
how the game works?
-[ Robotic ]
Yes. Yes. Welcome to Drinko.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, God!
-In this game,
you two will
take turns climbing my stair
and dropping two of your discs
into the Drinko board.
The disc will plink down
and land in these plastic cups
containing some of
my favorite beverages
of St. Patrick's Day, such as...
Guinness, Shamrock Shake,
and cabbage juice.
-Cabbage juice?
-Cabbage juice is one of
your favorite beverages?
-Yes! I love it, baby.
Then you must drink a cocktail
of those two chosen drinks
-Okay. Thank you, Drinko.
-You're welcome.
-I wonder who that is.
-I appreciate it, Drinko.
-Well, that's the robot, Drinko.
-Yeah, I know.
-Alright.
-Does he wear glasses?
-I don't know.
Taraji, you go up the stairs
and you can drop your first --
-[ Groaning ]
-Drinko.
Hey, Drinko! Drinko...
-I love cookies.
-[ Laughs ] Stop it!
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, here we go.
-[ Laughs ]
-Ready?
-Drop the disc whenever
you're ready.
-[ Chuckles ]
-This is for your --
-Does that tickle?
-You're making yourself a --
-[ Laughs ] Hey, hey, hey, hey
[ Laughter ]
Get my Christmas goose early
-Are you getting excited?
-[ Grunting ]
Cabbage juice!
-Is it cabbage juice?!
-[ Laughing ]
-That's your choice.
Now for the second disc.
-I would go more
towards that side.
[ Laughter ]
-So I go again.
-I would.
-[ Growls ]
[ Smacks ]
-Yeah, there you go.
-Drop the disc.
Oh! Hey, hey, hey!
-There you go.
-[ Indistinct vocalizations]
Jameson.
-Jameson.
-Huh?
-Jameson with cabbage juice.
-Hey!
-We call that...
[ Drums playing ]
-Drinko, stop.
Alright.
So here's the Jameson.
-You were supposed to stop i
when I came down.
-And here is the cabbage.
-Oh, oh, the drink.
Oh, that part.
Ew!
I might need this cup.
-Alright, here you go.
No! Why'd you smell it?!
Why would you smell it?
Don't smell it.
Just do it.
Just drink it.
-What happens if I don't?
-You just have to.
-[ Sighs heavily ]
[ Drums playing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're such a bitch.
♪♪♪♪
-Hey!
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-Alright, James, it is your turn
to ascend the stairs.
-Alright, thank you.
-That's gonna give me gas.
[ Laughter ]
-This way?
-[ Groaning ]
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Groaning continues ]
-Drinko, where do you want m
to put my disc?
-[ Laughs ]
You don't have to ask me twice
-Careful, buddy.
-Go ahead, James,
drop your Drinko discs.
You're used to handling discs.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Eek, ike, ink, ink,
mink, goo, goo, goo,
Boo, bee, bee, bah, bah, bah
bah, bah, bee, bo!
Four-leaf clover juice.
[ Crowd cheers ]
-What was it?
-Four-leaf clover juice.
-What does that mean?
-Basically, wheatgrass.
-It's the juice of four-leaf
clovers, like wheatgrass.
-Thank you.
-Basically, grass.
-Thank you, Drinko.
-Grass.
-Drinko's like Alexa, yeah
-It doesn't matter
what you get next.
-Again.
-It really doesn't.
-Let her rip, baby.
[ Laughter ]
There we go. It's coming down.
And it's going to...
-Oh!
-...Irish breakfast tea.
[ Audience groans ]
-So, you have breakfast tea.
-[ Laughs ]
-Whose hands are these?
Come here!
[ Laughter ]
-Show yourself!
-It's Drinko!
Sorry, I apologize.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Oh, this is gonna be
tough, man.
How am I gonna do this?
Wheatgrass juice
and another juice?
-Oh!
[ Audience groans ]
-Want me to smell it for you
-Ordinary probiotic.
-And -- And tea?
-Tea?
-This might hurt you.
-Smell it first.
Ew, it smells like grass.
-Why would I smell?
I like grass.
I like mowing the lawn.
I like what it does
to your white sneakers
after you mow the lawn
and get all green around it.
This might already be
in my stomach.
-Stop procrastinating.
-Hey, look.
-Go, go, drink, drink,
drink, drink, drink!
-Aaah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yay!
[ Fanfare ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I...
-Okay.
Now it's time
for the final round.
-Uh-oh-oh!
-This is going to be --
This is going to be a race
-Uh-oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Just make sure that we're safe.
Alright, we're going to
climb up.
We're going to drop our disc
here. Let's take our discs
And then, the first one
that lands is the winner,
so the second person
has to drink that shot.
Here we go.
-Oh, oh, eee.
-I beat you.
-Uh, uh, uh...
-Drinko.
-Get ready.
-You're very quiet.
Everything okay?
-I'm good.
I'm just having a drinko.
-Drinko, you better not be
looking up my skirt-o.
[ Laughter ]
-I told you, I love cookies.
Whoa!
-Hey, that is so not fair!
-Whoo!
-Absolutely wow.
-Not yet.
-That was such a...
That was so unfair.
-I cheated?
-No, but I love you.
I'll do it.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
What is it, though? Is it bad?
[ Drumroll ]
-Shamrock shake.
-It's Irish coffee.
-Shamrock shake?
-And Irish coffee.
-Hell, yeah! That's fantastic!
[ Audience groans ]
-What is that?
I was gonna order this later
This is unbelievable!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay!
-Ew, that looks.
-What is that, a protein?
-Is that the shake or...
-I'll smell it.
Coffee. That's good.
-Okay. Irish coffee and...
-Shake it, James, shake it
-And what?!
-Shamrock Shake.
-Oh, that's a Shamrock Shake
A Shamrock Coffee Shake.
-That's Mickey D's, man.
This is gonna be on the menu
next year.
-That's gonna be everything.
-Whoo!
Happy St. Patrick's Day,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Drums pounding ]
Taraji P. Henson, everyone
I love you!
-I love you!